Evangelical televangelist grifter Christian
Pat Robertson turns 91 in just a few days.
He is still going with his 700 Club show.
The show has been on the air for so long that
the list of things that Pat has said are demonic
is now really long as a reminder over the
years, the following can be or are demonic.
According to Pat Robertson, second hand sweater's
from a thrift shop, Ouija boards, yoga, Harry
Potter, Feng Shui, karate horoscopes, the
Twilight series, paintings of Buddha TV shows
about ghosts, Halloween psychics, girls who
levitate their friends at sleepovers and sometimes
even adopted children from other countries
can be demonically possessed, according to
Pat Robertson.
We now are adding something new to the list.
Even little babies just out of the womb, completely
vulnerable to the world's dangers, can be
demonically possessed.
Check this out.
Pat Robertson answering a question from a
caller named Lisa, as always, with this show.
I don't know if the caller is serious or participating
in some kind of satire.
It appears to be real, and Pat Robertson certainly
takes it seriously.
All right.
Here's the caller, Lisa from Fallon, Nevada.
My question is regarding demon possession,
10 babies be possessed and if those, does
the age of accountability come into play for
salvation?
You asked what Asian babies be possessed and
if so, does the age of accountability come
into play for salvation?
Well, the age of accountability has to do
at the point, you know, right from wrong.
And that normally doesn't take in place two
year old enough to understand something's
wrong.
So the age of accountability can be five,
it can be six can be before it can be three.
But can a baby be demon possessed?
I just believe if if if that child is born
to a family of devil worshipers, there's a
real possibility that the devil will think
that he has a claim over the child.
I mean, it's horrible to contemplate, but
I don't think they're protected in some fashion
from what I mean, a generational curse, but
normally a little a little baby.
As I say, there's no such thing as a as a
sinful baby.
Maybe they'll never know he or she is doing
anything wrong.
So they are free from the law, but not necessarily
free from the influence of Satan.
All right.
It could be a generational curse or simply
being born to devil worshipers.
And yes, a baby can be demonically possessed.
Remember that if there are soon to be parents
in the audience now, importantly, it wouldn't
be because the babies have sinned.
I guess that is that nice.
I don't know if that's better or worse.
The babies that are demonically possessed
would only be demonically possessed either
because of some kind of transgenerational
possession or because of something that that
the parents did or believed.
Maybe that's reassuring in some way.
You can't come out of the womb immediately
a sinner.
And if you think that this is entirely nonsense,
there are stories of parents who have killed
their kids because they become convinced the
kids are possessed by the devil.
It just happened a few months ago, December
twenty first article from KRC TV.
A Benton County couple in Missouri in custody
for torturing and beating the family of four
year old died.
And the couple said they were torturing the
family because the mother was possessed by
a demon.
Another one, from October of 2019, a man drowned
his six year old son while trying to cast
out a demon, I could go on.
There are many, many more of these.
It's not merely grifting.
It is a type of nonsense that has real world
impact.
Admittedly, the impact seems to be primarily
on those who are already probably quite mentally
ill and lacking mental health services.
But it's giving them ideas, if nothing else.
And Pat Robertson still going.
I don't know how long this show is going to
go on.
It's been on the air for a very long time.
By the way, for people who don't know the
story of the 700 Club, I'm going from memory.
I believe the reason it's called The 700 Club
is that early on Pat found I don't know if
it's actually 700 or roughly 700 of his friends.
Are people willing to give him money to start
this show?
It's extraordinarily lucrative and it has
been on air for decades.
I don't know if it's still airs on ABC Family.
I can't imagine a show less family friendly
than this to be, to be totally honest with
you.
But an incredibly successful institution,
The 700 Club with Pat Robertson.
And Pat, as I mentioned, just about 10 days,
March 22nd, March 22nd, Pat Robertson's birthday.
So that's what's going on there.
Babies, you know, I have a lot of friends
who are new parents.
Babies could be demonically possessed on Friday,
March 26th.
We are doing a one day membership blowout.
Why are we doing this?
I've been honest about why the pandemic is
getting a lot of people down economically.
In February, we had the most cancelations
of memberships of any month ever on The David
Pakman Show being a twenty eight day month.
We also had fewer new subscriptions.
We had a significant net loss of subscribers
in February.
So we're trying to do something to kick start
twenty twenty one.
On Friday, March 26th, we will be doing a
one day membership special.
It'll be a huge discount.
I believe the coupon code will be a covid-19
theme and it'll be it'll be good because of
growing vaccinations and decreasing cases
and all of that stuff.
I would love for you to get access to this
special.
All you have to do is get on my newsletter
at Join Pakman Dotcom, I'm sorry, at David
Pakman Dotcom, go to David Pakman dot com.
Sign up for the newsletter Friday morning,
March 26th.
You will get a perfect email from me telling
you exactly how to take advantage of this.
In the meantime, have you dealt with demonic
possession?
Let me know.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman